مهما كنت كبير صغير متوسطه دبر راسك
يا صيانه سياده وطن
[موسيقى]
مليون ونصف مليون شهيد يهللون الان
فبلادهم التي ضحوا بحياتهم من اجلها تسعى
لان تكون دوله العظمى يعمل لها العالم كله
الف حساب الرئيس الجزائري يقضي اياما
كامله في الجو متنقلا بين الصين وروسيا
ودول الخليج الكبرى نعم ها هو يقطع الحدود
مصافحا اعداء امريكا علنا ضاربا بتعليم
ولا يبالي الامر ليس عبثا او نزهه بل هو
تحضير لخطوه تؤرق الغرب عموما وامريكا
خصوصا ولا ننسى دلوعه اوروبا ونقصد فرنسا
ثعالب الصحراء يكسرون حاجز الصمت ويزمجرنا
في وجه الامريكان والغرب قائلين انتهى
دوركم ايها المستغلون ومن الان فصاعدا
سنصدع رؤوسكم بصوتنا الجهور وصفعاتنا
الموجعه ما سلبتموه منا في الماضي ستدفعون
ثمنه اليوم اضعافا مضاعفه اصحاب العيون
الضيقه يعلنونها للجزائريين نحن معكم
الصحراء فبالحديد الجزائري والخبره
الصينيه ستتحول يدنا الى قبضه حديديه نوجه
بها للغرب ضربه قاسمه ونستعيد مجدنا
الضائع ليقطع المشهد الدب الروسي قائلا
انا ايضا هنا ليحضر الجزائريون قلما ويحضر
الصينيون ورقه ساكتب شهاده وفاه غيلان
الغربي بنفسي ما هو سر الرحلات المكوكيه
التي يقوم بها الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد
تبون الى الصين وروسيا وكيف قصف تبون جبهه
الامريكان بكلمات قليله وما هي الخطوه
التي اتخذت الجزائر بالفعل والتي نزلت على
وجه الغرب كصفعه موجعه ولماذا تعشق بكينو
الجزائر وتحاول ارضاءها بكل الطرق لتعرف
اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع الفيديو
للنهايه سنكسر الحواجز ولا النبالي كفان
تواضعا نستحق ان نكون افضل مما نحن عليه
ويمكننا ذلك سنكسر كل الحواجز ولا النبالي
ومن يقف امام قطار طموحاتنا سي مصيره تحت
القضبان هكذا اعلنها الرئيس الجزائري عبد
المجيد تبون لتنزل كلماته على الغرب
كالصاعقه بل واكدها بالفعل والعمل فمنذ
اسبوع تقريبا قام تبون بزياره بكين بعد
ايام من زيارته لموسكو الرئيس الصيني
ويرحب به في استقبال عسكري مهيب وكانه
يقول هذه هي الجزائر بالنسبه لنا على
واشنطن ان تفهم الرساله فكل لبيب بالاشاره
يفهم يجلس تبويل مع شيعه على الطاوله
البيضاويه قائد ثعالب الصحراء يفجر مفاجاه
ويقول لقد قرر الخروج من عباءه الغرب نريد
ان ننضم الى منظمه بريكس ونضيف حرفا اخر
الاسم المنظمه ليكون اول حرف من اسم بلدنا
الجزائر تلمع عين الشي من المفاجاه
فالجزائر دوله لها ثقه لوها ليرد الحكيم
الصيني قائلا بالطبع مرحبا بكم ولكنكم
بذلك ستعادون الغرب وامريكا ليرد تبون في
حزم لا يهمنا سنقدم طلبا رسميا للانضمام
الى بريكس سنكسر كل الحواجز وليغضب من
يغضب صحيفه سي جي تي ان تسال الرئيس
الجزائري لماذا تحبون دائما التعامل مع
الصين بالذات لياتي الرد سريعا لان الصين
دوله تحترم الاخر ولا تقوم بالاملاءات
السياسيه على حلفائها انها تتعامل مع اي
دوله حليفه لها بمبدا الند للند دون النظر
الى قوه اوضعف هذه الدوله الصين لا تحاول
فرض هيمنتها السياسيه على حلفائها رغم
انها دوله العظمى ذات امكانات وقوه هائله
قوه تاهلها لفعل اي شيء تعلو ضحكات التنين
الصيني وكانه يقول في نفس الثعالب الصحراء
يكشفون جبهه الامريكان بقوه ودون حتى ان
نذكر اسمهم ولكن لماذا بريكس بالذات التي
تطمح الجزائر للانضمام لها وهل ستنجح في
تحقيق هذا الطموح بالفعل كابوس الليل وشبح
النهار بريكس والاسم الذي ترتعد فرائسه
ضباع واشنطن والغ عند سماعه فهو تحالف
مكون من خمس دول قويه هي البرازيل وروسيا
والهند والصين وجنوب افريقيا اصبح هذا
التحالف كابوس الليل المزعج وشبح النهار
المرعب للغرب عموما ولامريكا خصوصا فقد
تحول الى منظمه العملاقه تشكل اكثر من
اربعين بالمئه من سكان العالم واقوى
الاقتصادات المتناميه والصاعده بسرعه
الصاروخ تحت قياده الدب الروسي والتنين
الصيني الذي يستحوذ على 70% من اقتصاد
المنظمه تتعاون الدول الخمس في كل
المجالات الهامه خصوصا الاقتصاد والامن
وفي عام 2014 قاموا بانشاء بنك مشترك خاص
بهم باحتياطيا طارئ 200 مليار دولار فقد
اجتمعوا كلهم على هدف واحد هو كسر هيمنه
الغرب الاقتصاديه والسياسيه وتحجيم دور
مجموعه السبع الكبار التي تسيطر على 60%
من الاقتصاد العالمي ذات مره اراد الدب
الروسي اعلان تحديه للغرب فجلس بوتين امام
العالمي دول بريكس وكانه يعلن قيادته لهذا
التحالف قائلا قوه بريكس وتاثيرها العالمي
يزدادان بشكل مضطرد كل عام عما سبقه هذا
امر طبيعي فدول المنظمه معروفه جيدا
بثقلها السياسي وامكاناتها الاقتصاديه
والعلميه الضخمه يبدو ان الغرب ينتظر وحشا
شرسا اقترب على الاكتمال خصوصا وان اكثر
من اربعين دوله غير الجزائر تسعى للانضمام
الى رغم شروط المنظمه المعقده من اشهر تلك
الدول تركيا ومصر والسعوديه وايران وغيرها
من الدول التي قد تقلب الطاوله في وجه
غيلان الغرب المشهد مرعب يا عزيزي فغالبا
ستكون هناك حرب تكسير عظام لن يكون فيها
مكان للرحمه وحتى ان انتصر الغرب في
النهايه وهذا صعب جدا فسيكون منهكا لدرجه
لن تجعله يقوى حتى على الاحتفال بانتصاره
ولكن ما هو موقف روسيا من انضمام الجزائر
للمنظمه وماذا ستجنث علب الصحراء من
الانضمام الى هذا الحلف الطريق نحو دوله
عظمى حسمت الجزائر الامر وتقدمت بطلب رسمي
للانضمام الى منظمه بريكس ليس هذا فحسب بل
ان الرئيس الجزائري اعلن ان بلاده على
استعداد لدعم البنك التابع للمنظمه
بمساهمه اوليه قدرها مليار ونصف المليار
دولار رحبت روسيا وصلوا بانضمام الجزائر
وانتما هذا فعلا فستجني ثعالب الصحراء
الكثيره والكثير مثل زياده نفوذها
السياسيه بقوه وتنويع موارد اقتصادها
القائمه على عوائد الغاز والنفط ستكشر
ثعالب الصحراء عن انيابها وتمزق عباءه
الغرب السوداء القادمه ويتخلصون من
سيطرتهم والاستدانه منهم نهائيا فدول
بريكس تتمتع باقتصاد قوي يجعلها تقدم على
طلب كميات هائله من مصادر الطاقه من
الجزائر خصوصا الصين التي تعتبر اكبر
مستوردا للنفط ناهيك عن استثمارات بكين
التي ستتضاعف في الدوله الافريقيه الطموحه
هذا غير استثمارات باقي دول الم الهندي
والبرازيل مليارات اضافيه من الدولارات
ستنمر وسيتضاعف دخل الجزائر ما يعني زياده
قدرتها على سداد ديونها والتفرغ لوضع
اللمسات الاولى لمستقبل مشرق وهذا بالطبع
يؤرق الغرب وامريكا الذين سيهربلون سريعا
قبل ان يسقطوا من فوق بساط السياده الذي
ينسحب من تحت اقدامهم الان وهنا السؤال
لماذا تعشق الصين الجزائر ولماذا ترجو
رضاها وموادتها رد الجميل بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كانت الصين قد فقدت
مقعدها الدائمه في مجلس الامن لصالح
تايوان حينها اعلنت الجزائر صراحه للصين
لا تقلقي لن نهدا حتى تستعيد ارثاك الشرعي
تمر السنون وتصبح الجزائر في مقدمه الدول
التي قدمت مشروع استعاده الصين لمقعدها
الدائم وياتي عام
1971 لتقر الامم المتحده باستعاده الصيني
مقعدها الدائم وحصولها على كل الامتيازات
الخاصه بهذا المقعد
[موسيقى]